let's go next to trey from missouri trey
you're on the air
can you hear me yes i can
um thank you first of all thanks for
taking the call dave um i just had a
quick question so
you know one of the things that you've
outlined is that there are sort of three
different republican groups you've got
the pro-business class
you have the social conservatives and
then i i can't remember what was the
other group it's like the freedom
libertarian people now i would add a
fourth to that now but maybe that's
where your question is going so i'll let
you i'll let you ask the question first
well the question i was going to ask is
that you know tom hartman um you know
had mentioned that there was there was
another sort of a group that sometimes
doesn't get a lot of popularity and it's
the group of people who have a
legitimate economic grievance
about their jobs being taken away from
nafta tpp and all these other um you
know neoliberal trade deals and so i was
wondering is it is it possible that if
the democrats can sharpen their message
on trade jobs protection
protections and whatnot that they could
potentially get some of those voters
back who voted for trump in 2016 and
only switched over to biden just after
the last four years
yes now here's the thing
what we would have to be concerned with
is the group of people you describe
who aren't also part of one of the three
groups i mentioned and who are more
loyal to that than to the legitimate
economic grievance does that make sense
and i can say more about that if it
doesn't
i was just curious because like i said i
i know that it's unlikely that we're
going to help the people who are you
know the social conservatives or you
know the pro-business class just because
we have different views economically and
socially than these people yeah but i
figured that that if we sharpen our
message which i don't know how because
the the current mainstream democratic
party is is so feeble and unable to put
a coherent message together yeah i
thought that that there was going to be
at least one possibility that we could
we could get the people back
economically but by running on an
economic populist agenda that says we're
going to fight for your jobs we're done
letting people take your jobs overseas
and i feel like that might be a
potential so i would tweet one thing
about that for me the running on the
populist messages left and right i'm not
huge on it because populism at the end
of the day is a rhetoric it's not a set
of policy ideas so i'm basically with
your the the the spirit of your message
but i'm less interested in the so-called
populist rhetoric which can just go
nowhere or be misused i'm more
interested in just a coherent
pro-middle-class worker
social democracy policy and where i am a
hundred percent behind you is
what you're saying that democrats could
do that might appeal to some disaffected
republicans it should also appeal to
center left people who just don't vote
because they don't see the democratic
party as having their back so it's not
just the republicans that that would
target
so so i think that that that better
economic message and policy most
importantly would actually appeal to
disaffected centrists people on the left
and some of these less ideological
republicans that you talk about
man thanks for the call
thank you trey trey from missouri
very important phone call i i love it
sponsoring today's show is the new book
by jason murchie called wisdom a very
valuable virtue that cannot be bought
this is an excellent book i've been
reading through
no book can really teach you how to be
wise but this is a really well
researched nonfiction book that helps
readers
grow to love the pursuit of wisdom which
is really a process at the end of the
day and if you spend just two minutes
watching my show
you'll know america has a significant
lack of wisdom in many ways republicans
have made an art form out of failing to
think critically they have their
flexible and exclusive values moral
dogmatism
right now is probably one of the low
points in this particular sense in
american history with trump tribalism
the pandemic and just the the lack of
wise thinking
the author of the book jason murchie
believes that while liberals ought to
aspire to be tolerant and compassionate
right-wing extremism and political
chicanery
must be resisted and overcome and
murchie really brings a refreshing
array of insightful and interesting
quotations and personal reflections it's
a
deep and wide investigation into what
wisdom is
i've been really enjoying reading
through it it's really easy to read in
chunks each chapter kind of stands on
its own
so you can jump into the book very
quickly it's a book that could have a
really powerful impact on a lot of
readers pick up a copy at david
davidpakman.com
wisdom
the link is down below